avec volane fera bon jour hélène bonjour
pelé ravi de vous retrouver hélène à la
une de la presse aujourd'hui la
poursuite on en parlait à l'instant bien
sûr de la guerre en ukraine bientôt cinq
semaines de guerre l'ukraine où l'armée
russe ne semble plus progressé une
guerre d'usure est elle en train de
s'installer la russie serait-elle en
train de s'enliser d'après la croix il
apparaît désormais que moscou a
sous-estimé la capacité de combat des
ukrainiens et la résistance de la
population et que sans solution
diplomatique
ce conflit pourrait durer encore des
mois sur le front diplomatique
précisément dans financial times affirme
que la russie dont les émissaires
rencontrent leurs homologues ukrainiens
aujourd'hui à istanbul en turquie ne
demande plus la dénazification de
l'ukraine et qu'elle serait prête à
laisser kiev rejoindre lieu à condition
que l'ukraine reste je cite non-alignés
militairement le figaro note de son côté
que moscou semble désormais l'aisne se
focaliser sur les provinces séparatistes
du dombass et que kiev semble renoncer à
intégrer l'otan mais le journal affirme
néanmoins que les armes vont continuer à
imprimer se demande même si ces
négociations interviennent trop tôt pour
avoir une chance d'aboutir en suisse le
temps pauline fait état de la méfiance
de kiev confronté à la menace d'un
possible non respect futur des promesses
par la russie le journal évoque un
précédent toujours vif dans la mémoire
des ukrainiens l'accord signé avec
moscou en
1994 qui n'a pas empêché vladimir
poutine derrière l'ukraine selon cet
accord qui est appelée mémorandum de
budapest l'ukraine renonçait aux armes
nucléaires présentes sur son territoire
est hérité de l'union soviétique en
échange du respect de ses frontières par
moscou c'est dans ce contexte que le
wall street journal affirme que le
ligueur que russe roman abramovitch et
des négociateurs ukrainiens ont souffert
d'un possible empoisonnement après une
réunion à kiev au début du mois selon
les sources du quotidien américain cette
tentative pourrait être le fait de
partisans d'une dur à moscou qui
chercherait selon elle à saboter ses
négociations pour tenter mettre un terme
à la guerre en ukraine et on y reviendra
dans le décryptage sur ces soupçons
d'empoisonnement à 7h40 les pourparlers
russo ukrainien on en parlait avec 2vic
de foucauld à istanbul qui débute donc
aujourd'hui dans la ville turque une
façon pour la turquie de se placer au
centre du jeu diplomatique d'après le
journal émirati the national ankara
serait même devenue le point d'appui
privilégié de l'occident en raison de
ses liens étroits avec les belligérants
le quotidien relève aussi que la turquie
est membre de l'otan n'a toutefois pas
adhérer aux sanctions occidentales
contre la russie et qu'elle a même
dérouler le tapis rouge aux oligarques
russes une tentative de rester dans les
bonnes grâces de vladimir poutine selon
des nationals le patron du kremlin avec
lequel pauline emmanuel macron à
discuter à 17 reprises au téléphone au
cours des quatre derniers mois a calculé
de new york times qui évoque
l'interminable diplomatie russe du
président français personne ne peut
accuser le président macron d'avoir
ménagé ses efforts pour éviter d amorcer
ou arrêter la guerre en ukraine écrit le
journal qui dresse un bilan plutôt
mitigé de cette intense activité
diplomatique
si la diplomatie se mesure à la
persévérance monsieur macron est un
diplomate suprême si elle se mesure à
ces concrétisations le verdict est moins
favorable de new york times qui ironise
enfin pauline sur le fait que le
président français consacrent tant
d'heures à ce conflit en ukraine qu'il a
peu de temps pour la petite affaire de
l'élection présidentielle française qui
a lieu maintenant dans moins de deux
semaines dans douze jours exactement un
mot également du sommet historique
hélène qui a réuni hier le secrétaire
d'état américain et ses homologues
d'israël et de quatre pays arabes dans
le dessert dans le désert du néguev au
sud de l'état les poignées de mains
entre les chefs de la diplomatie des
états unis israël d'égypte du maroc des
émirats arabes unis et de bahreïn font
la une on le voit du jerusalem post qui
salue leur habilité affiché face à
l'iran et rapporte qu'un participant à
ce sommet s'est réjoui de voir se former
a mis autant moyen-orientale jeu si tu
arrêtes autre quotidien israélien est
nettement plus sceptiques ce fantasme
enfin enfantin qu'une normalisation
ouverte avec le monde arabe ferait
s'évaporer les palestiniens a été abordé
par le secrétaire d'état américain qui a
rappelé que la plupart des israéliens
préférerait oublier les accords
d'abraham ne sont pas un substitut au
progrès entre les palestiniens et les
israéliens prévient le journal on ne se
quittent pas là dessus on a moqué ici r
comment
échapper le scandale de la gifle
administrée par l'acteur américain will
smith à son camarade chris rock en
pleine cérémonie des oscars la photo de
l'incident fait la une ce matin de
nombreux quotidiens à travers le monde
nous on a préféré retenir pour vous les
dessins de presse et ils sont nombreux
qui s'en inspirent dans celui de blow up
our daily telegraph voici ce qu'il reste
du panneau hollywood après le passage du
gie fleurs will smith où ils se
mettraient compensions le sel dimanche
soir de l'oscar du meilleur acteur ou
plutôt de l'oscar de la normalisation de
la violence selon mike golding dont le
dessin est publiée par image
brian scott pour des indipendente
recommande plutôt électeurs américains
de suivre une thérapie de gestion de la
colère thérapie d'ailleurs également
recommandé à vladimir poutine et au
leader nord-coréen kim jong eun
je crois a signé ben jennings pour deux
gardiennes qui montre une présentatrice
comme vous lançant son correspondant de
guerre en direct depuis les oscars
l'occasion aussi pour moi pauline de
saluer le travail remarquable de nos
correspondants et envoyés spéciaux de
france 24 sur les terrains de vrais
conflits et notamment en ukraine
remarquable c'est le mot merci beaucoup
hélène et à tout à l'heure dans paris
direct une revue de presse bien sûr à
retrouver sur en podcast est sur votre
place vos plates formes d'écouté
habituel et vous les colts guys l'école
kenza ouais ça me passionne les affaires
elle les affaires non classées